Russian State media has reported that
jailed Wall Street Journal correspondent
Evan gershkovic has been formally
charged with Espionage an allegation
that the journal and the U.S government
vehemently deny the charge of Espionage
is ridiculous his detention is the first
case of an American journalist arrested
by Moscow on allegations of spying since
the Cold War and has prompted a growing
list of individuals organizations and
government officials to call for his
release
on March 29th while on a reporting trip
gershkovich was detained in the city of
yakatirenberg around 800 miles east of
Moscow by Russia's main Security Agency
on March 30th gershkovich was seen being
escorted into a vehicle after appearing
in a Moscow Court the Press service of
the Court said he was ordered to be held
in custody until May 29th according to
State News Agency Tas Russia's Federal
Security Bureau said gershkovic acting
on the instructions of the American side
collected information constituting a
state secret about the activities of one
of the Enterprises of the Russian
military industrial complex the journal
said it vehemently denies the
allegations from the FSB and seeks the
immediate release of our trusted and
dedicated reporter Evan gershkovich we
stand in solidarity with Evan and his
family
the arrest of the 31 year old reporter
marked the latest diplomatic Flashpoint
between Moscow and Washington the
targeting of American citizens by
Russian government is unacceptable
we condemn the Detention of Mr gerskovic
in the strongest in the strongest terms
we also condemn the Russian government's
continued targeting and repression of
journalists
on March 31st President Biden urged
Russia to release gershkovic
to Russia
gershkovic was accredited to work as a
journalist in Russia by the country's
foreign Ministry at the time of his
detention
Biden said the U.S didn't plan any
expulsion of Russian journalists or
diplomats in response that's not the
plan right now
repeat Journal editor-in-chief Emma
Tucker spoke to CNN's Anderson Cooper
about gershkovich's detainment and the
charges against him rubbish
um Evan was doing what reporters do and
what he did very well he was out there
Gathering news talking to people
reporting providing an eyewitness
account of what's going on inside Russia
speaking at a news conference on April
3rd NATO Secretary General Yen
stoltenberg said gershkovich's arrest
was of great concern it is important to
respect freedom of the press the rights
of journalists
earned the rights to ask questions and
to do their job so therefore we call on
his immediate release at the United
Nations Russia's Ambassador declined to
discuss gershkovich's case in any detail
citing what he referred to as the
separation of powers in the Russian
justice system today secretary blinking
talked to minister
on that issue
but that will be decided not by Minister
a lot of secretary blinking but by by
investigation and by the evidence that
the investigation could provide for the
court afternoon everybody on April 4th
White House Press Secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre said the U.S will continue
pressing for his release and seek
Consular access to him Evan is not a spy
Evan has never been a spy Evan has never
worked for the U.S government that same
day gershkovich's lawyers met with him
in prison and reported that Evan's
health is good and he is grateful for
the outpouring of support from around
the world Secretary of State Anthony
blinken said on April 5th that the state
Department's process to reach an
official wrongfully detained
determination was pending in my own mind
there's no doubt that he's being
wrongfully detained by Russia which is
exactly what I said to foreign minister
lavrov when I spoke to him over the
weekend
and insisted that Evan B released
immediately
but I want to make sure that as always
because there is a formal process that
we go through it and we will and I
expect that to be
to be completed soon on April 6 a Moscow
Court said that it would hear an appeal
from gershowitz's lawyers on April 18th
the court could uphold his continued
detention order him move to another jail
allow him house arrest or Grant him bail
foreign